in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Nate
and Kerry are with us hey how are you
hey Dave how's it going welcome welcome
where y'all from
we are from Spring Hill Tennessee a
whole 30 miles from here
not even yeah welcome okay cool good to
have you neighbor
yeah so you're here to do a debt-free
scream yes sir and traveled all the way
and how much have you paid off a hundred
and ten thousand dollars I love it
excellent and how long did that take
twenty three months to the name boom you
kicked it
what's your household income range
during that time well we started off
Dave at about a hundred and seven and by
the end of the time we paid off the debt
there we were making about 173 whoa what
do you guys do for a living well Kerri
is the schoolteacher and I'm an attorney
turned podcaster so I just launched a
podcast called the industrialist and we
interview manufacturing leaders in the
shooting and hunting industry so
apparently it went bananas well that was
the attorney job something jumped go up
73,000 in 23 months
yeah that's pretty incredible way to go
so that added to you picked up this
extra job called a podcast is that what
happened sure change come from the
bottom line is I just got really good at
doing what I did as an attorney Oh
frankly wasn't real passionate about it
so but had to have the job had to have
the income to pay off this debt no I was
a slave and we were slave our family was
a slave to this desk ten thousand was
law school it was it was law school and
about fifteen thousand on credit cards
which we used to live off of after law
school got it yeah so carry what
happened 23 months ago that this guy
becomes a beast I mean or somebody did
somebody did not a teacher it was
nothing to do with my income I mean you
guys changed everything change
everything
um just life it was not going the way
that we had hoped
and we really hit a rock bottom when we
came back to Franklin and he was having
trouble finding a good attorney job and
he had to find just something and we
knew that this was just not the route we
wanted to go eventually having kids and
a home and we just knew if we wanted to
have a good life that we needed to make
big changes so what was the thing
exactly 23 months ago that was the last
straw that you said that's it we're
going to change well Dave I had an
attorney job where I was making less
money than I ever had as a manufacturing
leader which is what I did prior to
becoming an attorney and I just I
couldn't believe that I had put in all
that effort at Law School did really
really well in law school just killed
law school top top of the class but it
wasn't painting out with with money and
I think it was just God saying to us
you're not doing things my way so I'm
gonna teach you how to do it right by
putting you in difficult circumstance
but was there a certain event one night
you just said that's it what started
this what was the catalyst that caused
you to turn the corner I guess get
things generally weren't going direct
yeah I can't remember dealing with
things I was a general liability
attorney so I did some some business
dispute litigation but mainly just civil
general liability and there there was
just a particular set of circumstances
there with the job that I just felt like
this isn't why I went to law school and
just one night went to Barnes & Noble
right over here up the road and bought
Total Money Makeover and and started
making some change it's good there you
go so he comes on with the book carry
and say okay we're gonna do this and you
said what and I said okay put me on a
budget and here we go just like that
you're easy okay very cool well
congratulations
so 23 months of beans and rice pretty
much well I don't eat beans I would say
spaghetti sauce okay very cool so when
people ask how do you pay off a hundred
and
thousand dollars in two years what do
you tell the secret to getting out of
debt is David it's real simple you have
to view that debt as your mortal enemy
you have to hate that debt with just a
holy hatred and you have to plant a
tomahawk in its skull somewhere there's
a government bureaucrat sucking their
thumb right now you're exactly right
though yeah it has to get visceral
doesn't it absolutely I get this level
of passion or you'd lost your dadgum
mind and you're getting rid of it it's
this thing has invaded my home and I'm
throwing her out yeah
and that that's and then you do that and
then it changes everything so how does
it feel now incredible totally free to
do whatever we want live wherever
wherever we want have whatever type of
profession we want to do it's great now
heard a rumor Carrie's got a connection
to Ramsey solution I do have a lovely
twin sister Katie Meyers in the audience
here watching and she works on our team
yes sir she does oh so was she in the
background cheering your honor did she
know this was happening or yeah she was
definitely a catalyst and got us
involved in a class here at a local
church and was definitely a motivator
along the way cool so you went through
Financial Peace University well yes we
went together all right very cool good
good well congratulations you too very
proud thank you love it best visual of
the week thank you
Nate and Carrie from Spring Hill
Tennessee a suburb of Nashville a
hundred and ten thousand dollars paid
off in 23 months making 107 to 173 oh
and don't forget JW only JW 19 months 19
months that's the reason for doing all
this right there that's right all right
we tried try not to scare him but let's
count it down
we'll have a debt-free scream three two
one weird
that is fabulous
way to go you guys he's heard his dad
yell before his dad's yeah that might
have might have had a tomahawk and
that's awesome that's fabulous hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind